look at what's going on at u-pen there
is a transgender quote-unquote swimmer
there is a man named will thomas
and he swam on the men's team and he did
fine on the men's team he was there for
three seasons
but now he's
saying that he's a woman and he's
competing on the women's team and
surprise surprise he's breaking all the
records
wow amazing oh my gosh
he's brand new to the team and he's
breaking like all the records wow he
must be the greatest woman ever gosh he
is the most impressive woman
ever at the akron
zippy invitational over the weekend
kind of a funny name
uh thomas won
uh won one race by a whopping 38 seconds
over his teammate
he's he's setting records for pen he's
setting records for the meet he's
setting he's setting all sorts of
records according to outkick
now what do the teammates say
this is according to a teammate who
wants to remain anonymous obviously for
fear of blowback she says
pretty much everyone individually has
spoken to our coaches about not liking
this our coach just really likes winning
he's like most coaches i think secretly
everyone knows it's the wrong thing to
do
this person went on said when the whole
team is together we have to be like oh
my gosh go leah leah is what this guy
now goes by leah oh my gosh go leah
that's great you're amazing it's very
fake
added this student and of course it's
it's fake that's the worst part of this
i don't
i don't care about women's swimming
or
tennis or what i don't i don't care
not the biggest sports guy in the world
generally and i
you know like uh i guess i'm like sort
of interested in the nba but i'm really
not interested in the wnba
you know i'm not and i know that a lot
of this argument from the right pushing
back on transgenderism is we've got to
save women's sports i don't care about
women's sports it'd be nice let the
women have their sports let them win
their awards and their scholarships it's
fine i have no problem i'm not against
women's sports but that's not what's so
wrong about this
okay the thing that's really wrong is
what that teammate is saying
which is that everyone has to lie
we're all being made to lie all the time
and we we're not even allowed to lie
in a quiet way we have to lie in a
really enthusiastic way we have to say
oh yes
wow you yes bruce jenner you are a
beautiful woman right we're all and
we're all celebrating it right
it's all and no i know i'm more
enthusiastic than anybody yes and you uh
will thomas you're an amazing
female swimmer
wow great good good job you know but no
one no one believes it
no one believes it the swimmer doesn't
believe it bruce jenner i don't think
believes it and has said it various
times i'm not really a woman so it's
just not
it's that culture of lies that's really
the problem
and we're seeing it and we're we're all
trying to dance around that so even the
conservatives will say well he's
biologically a male he's a biological
male he's a biologist she's a biological
female no
as if there's some some kind of other
male or female
like you can be a biological male but a
spiritual female a biological female but
a but a psychological male no he's just
just boys and girls
boys and girls
and we're all well it's just not fair to
the female runners and swimmers who
cares it's just not right is the problem
it's just not it's just not true that's
the real problem
the runners and the swimmers and the
models and that's all
secondary to the to the it's just
not true and the truth
ought to be pursued because the truth
will set you free did you like that clip
be honest i can take it i did you well
if you did
even if you didn't please subscribe ring
that bell get the notifications for when
i have new videos out
and if you really want to get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast type
in the michael knowles show boom
subscribe
boom five star review boom
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you